[Musique]
quel est l'endroit le plus silencieux
sur la planète une chambre et pas
n'importe laquelle une chambre
anéchoïque ce qui veut dire qu'elle a
été conçue spécialement pour absorber
les ondes sonores elle est située dans
les laboratoires de la compagnie
microsoft près de seattle aux états unis
l'endroit sert à tester notamment le
bruit produit par certains objets du
quotidien
à -26 décibels le silence est telle
qu'on y entend son propre coeur battre
dans la nature les chercheurs ont
démontré que les endroits réputés les
plus silencieux sont les grands déserts
de la planète déserts arides en afrique
notamment
mais là non plus on n'échappe pas au
bruit des avions au dessus du désert de
glace que l'antarctique pas de corridors
aériens
par contre près des stations de
recherche on ne peut éviter le ronron
des génératrices mais c'est dans les
villes où vit la majorité de la
population mondiale que le silence se
fait le plus rare après la pollution de
l'air l'organisation mondiale de la
santé considère la pollution sonore dans
certaines régions comme le deuxième
facteur de risque environnemental le
plus dangereux pour les humains l' oms
recommande un niveau de bruit maximal de
55 décibels
mais dans un rapport publié cet hiver
l'onu a analysé soixante et une ville du
monde et le vacarme urbain allait
souvent bien au delà de cette limite
selon ce palmarès new york est la ville
nord américaine la plus bruyante tandis
que dans le monde ce titre revient à
dacca la capitale du bangladesh